did you know that um well I don't know
and I don't know exactly but they said
starfish could be gay I heard somewhere
so I don't know what we're gonna do
today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block get that
hitter
[Music]
hello there
later for me to slap that parking brake
my cellphone
[Music]
and that is you know shine by Bishop
Gunn grateful to them for being alive in
the same time period as we are or as I
am anyway I can't speak for you but oh
did you think about that what if you
were in some people you might not get to
know somebody because they born at a
different time period think about that
think about that oh do you know uh you
know Carol you know little Carol and
people are like I don't know her yeah
cuz she was born in 1804 oh well then ya
don't know her think about that what
about big Samuel you know big Samuel
with the braids he got the French braids
and he you know he always selling bags a
yeast down there by the river
you know yeasty Sam no Oh where's he
from
oh you know he's from you know by the
riverbanks uh know when how old is he go
he's about 25 you know he was born in uh
in 1834 oh well
don't know him can't know him and this
is why what if what if your best friend
you know
isn't even born yet they're gonna be
born in two years and you and your so
you missing out because y'all's time
isn't synced up think about that you saw
you next thing you know you milling
around a preschool and people like a us
you know hey hey hey hey hey Judy hey
what you doing out here by the preschool
and Judy says oh well you know little ah
little [ __ ] oh you're right there the
four year old I think we got vibes
you know friendship vibes you know
buddies you know but you know
Vegeta's but you know teamwork team tits
hashtag errs you know friendship and
they're like oh no you know you
twenty-five years older than her so you
can't hang out here I'm gonna call the
police you know timing is so important
that you know timing is important and
then you never know so know you might
miss your best friend
because you the timing wasn't right you
know you might be your best friend might
be four and you might be 61 but y'all
you know now and now you can't even be
friends with somebody because the law
says it's [ __ ] up or the law says it's
wrong it's wrong if a senior citizen
wants to be buddies with a
seven-year-old with somebody that's in
second grade and wants to you know hang
out with them on the weekends or
whatever and do cigarettes or whatever
it's interesting timing how important it
is I'll tell you about this timing so I
just crossed the International Date Line
and I thought it was going to be a
really good episode hosted by Lester
Holt but it isn't it is um
it is a line let me research it for you
real quick
International Date Line here's what it
is it was established in 1884 it passes
through the mid Pacific Ocean and
follows a hundred and eighty degrees
longitude north-south line on the
earth so that means it's up and down
it's long it's top to bottom you know
it's it's it's a horizontal now it's
vertical line it's located halfway
around the world from the Prime Meridian
and when you cross it the day changes
well it's an imaginary line also it's
not really real so you can't get out
there and you know you're not gonna see
a big twizzler running from the North
Pole to the South Pole or something
you're not gonna see you know any buoys
or anything like that or you know a guy
out there with a whistle pointing you
know Thursday this way Wednesday that
way you know it's just it's where the
day changes anyway I crossed it when I
flew to Australia and back and I'm now
back here in the US on US soil and I'm
back here and I'm in a new studio we're
in a new studio so if you're on the
youtubes
is you know this is different it's
different in here we have more space
hello
might sound different in the back when I
yell hello and nobody's listening so
just you know some changes going on I
walk to him I'm nervous you know I walk
in and I'm in my mind it's like oh wow
it's just gonna be if you're gonna feel
suddenly like home and it's gonna be you
know nothing everything will be kind of
setup and everything will be but you
know we have accounts that you know
premature Nick he got it on it you know
so we have some furniture we got a chair
we have a couple bags had some
croissants somebody had that are empty
now from the coffee bean couple couple
sea bags couple croissant bags and we
have a lot of empty space and a lot of
possibility those are the things that we
have in here
so yeah just a lot going on at the
second you know being in a new place
getting home having to come into the
into the studio and decide okay do I
want to be confident when I get in here
you know because Nick Cyr Gianni is here
with their new movie his new movie is
out now the movie MA MA and go see it
it's basically like it's like
fraternities meet kind of interracial
dating I think is what it is kind of
like a you know what is that called
it's like kappa apartheid alpha-omega or
something like that it's like yeah it's
just you know it's got kind of a hurt
it's really good as scary we'll see I'm
gonna check it out
but we're definitely excited that you
know to support him and be supportive of
him the but yeah man I got in here and I
just didn't I was like man okay do I be
nervous do I just be confident you'll
walk in here and act like okay I know
everything we're gonna do and um and you
know Nick and Johnny had already been
here they move stuff in so they've had a
little more acquaintance and they were
just excited they were excited about the
opportunity and so you know I just I
just try to ride their excitement
because I honestly just a little bit
scared I guess you know like taking on
new responsibilities or the rent in here
is twice as much you know the walls
don't look the same not to mention the
other places going you know the other
studio is not you know everything's out
of there so it's I mean it still exists
like in a location inside of us but in
our memory and in in time but it doesn't
exist the same anymore right now and so
we're here we're in something new it's
like we're traveling like when a baby
comes out the body you know when a baby
comes out the body they got think about
all of that
first the baby's been in there getting
jacked up on it you know on that mom
sauce whatever mom has been having sweet
potatoes chocolate pickles a little bit
of freaking gin you know maybe a little
bit of Vaughn Myers rum or something
that night especially if it's wintertime
a little better that you know what is
that egg batter in Cognac or whatever
the eggnog so the baby you know when
they decide to leave the womb they
really it's a brave move because it's
basically they're just daring they're
laying up in there it's like being at
the Hampton Inn but the room kind of you
know but nobody's the maid hadn't come
and cleaned your room in a while and
they got a lot of you know they got you
too baby you're in that little Hampton
Inn inside of your mother and they got
the fasces over there and they got the
you know just a bunch of Pizza Hut
little you know boxes from all the
snacks you've been having you got to go
and then you you know you slide out of
your mother out into the world and it's
a new experience and that's where we are
right now in this new experience so yeah
just nervous excited for the opportunity
hopeful I think I had a moment where I
was like oh wow I'm part of like its you
know I really have to be more part of a
team right now then I'm just you know
because I need I need help i need help
from my coworkers and I'm just you know
I'm grateful to have them man I got just
got back from Australia and I just I
gotta say it was amazing the last show
they had 3,000 people in Brisbane
Brisbane Australia and man I can't I'm
trying to think of like what it feel
just I don't know if he feels like you
can't thank everybody enough it feels
like you know you walk out there I felt
like damn Joel Osteen out there
I felt like I wish I had a big water gun
full of holy water and just you know
just filling people's mouths up from 50
yards away you know just just just
pressure washing the devil off of people
it was just you know it was like a bit
it was just it was interesting and then
it's hard to tell if people are laughing
as much when it's in a big space but I
got such a great response just from
people over social media and they went
to the koala park and saw the koalas and
saw the Kangaroos and if you never seen
a kangaroo they it's like it's like when
they're it's kind of like the first time
somebody tells you oh that's your cousin
or your second cousin or they introduced
you to your uncle that you never met
you're like damn uncle Ronnie got some
short arms and a big ass you know oh
dang you know uncle Ronnie's out there
eating leaves off of her off of the
shrubbery like damn it may it may be I
was shocked that I that Hulme that that
their species I was shocked that we're
all have you know atoms in US that are
similar because a kangaroo is like
something you know it's basically a
kangaroo is like the El Camino
of the animal kingdom it is the it is
the it's got a [ __ ] it's got a I
don't know what it it's kind like a
dragon tail that got that it's got the
body of a arm kind of like a thick girl
like a real thick [ __ ] so that likes to
fight you know kind of like a thick girl
that doesn't you know that likes to
thumb wrestle real heavily with others
and it and then it's got the head of
like a kind of a dog like a um Doberman
like a lean Doberman that's on keto diet
sugar free Doberman that sfd and it's it
just blows your mind you're like holy
[ __ ] this is an animal now and that's
Australia it's got unique animals
it's got unique animals and you know
what one thing I loved about Australia
I'll say this Australia is if there's a
country that I've visited that I could
go easily see myself to live in it would
be Australia and then one of the things
that I loved is that they still have a
strong sense of being Australian it
feels like it felt like to me this is my
perception and at the airport you could
still go say bye to your loved ones or
you can meet somebody at the gate so
it's just really beautiful because you
still see like a lot of like what it
means to travel and be somewhere new
like in America you can't see that
anymore when I was young
your mom could walk you to the gate and
watch you cry in the little tunnels you
flew off to meet grandma and that's
natural you know if you're a child and
you're about to fly for hours to see
some senior citizens I mean I don't make
I don't bring a tear to anybody's eye
and especially if you if you if you step
grandfather is addicted to Marlboro Reds
and he does them indoors and [ __ ] and
you can't eat you know so right after
dessert right after a couple cups of
pudding at Grandma's you got to sit
there in and get that secondhand smoke
off a poppy but but yeah I mean one of
the things about that is you when you
see people hug at the gating you see
people like say goodbye to each other at
the gate like you couldn't Australia you
see like human affection you see human
interaction and it makes you kind of
gives like more of a meaning to what
travel is and so I saw I would see that
at the different place when we flew I
think - I think we had maybe seven
flights or six flights within the
country once we got there and you you're
like oh wow this is oh yeah this person
is coming to see someone this person is
leaving someone they care about and and
it just it reminded me of that time in
the u.s. when you could do that you
could go to the gate and greet somebody
and greet a loved one you didn't
have a ticket you could still be there
to see them come or to see them go and I
miss that it just added so much more
meaning to travel it added so much more
meaning to coming and going
because you saw others you know just to
see somebody say goodbye to someone it's
like oh wow that's human interactionists
that's connection to see somebody give a
kiss to somebody that they that they you
know maybe they they're not gonna see
him for you know a couple weeks or a
couple months or who knows how long and
in your mind you process oh I wonder I
wonder if they you know if this is their
first time this ever their first weekend
that they ever hung out and it was great
and now one of them's leaving Earth
they've been together for years and one
of them's leaving you get to see a kid
get get to the gate and run up and and
his uncle was there to give him a big
hug and you know or the grandpa or the
grandpa and grandma are there see him
hug the baby and lift up the baby for
the first time you get to see that and
it just you know I think that's to me
that's when something happened in
America years ago when something changed
a lot was right around that time and I
feel like it was after 9/11 when that
things just got a lot stricter and a lot
more serious and and uh and we started
to take out some of the things that
reminded us how human we are but that's
one thing I loved about Australia was
seeing that that's one of the honestly
my favorite things about the country was
just seeing that getting to see that at
the air at the airports when we get in
and when we leave it was just uh I don't
know I liked it
you know I like just seeing him I like
seeing humans be able to I don't know
just express some of their feelings and
have a space to do that or or just I
don't know I just it reminded me that I
was human a little bit more it reminded
me that I was amongst others just seeing
connection and seeing it just I don't
know it did say it was something
different it was
then I wasn't used to you know I saw
some exotic animals but one of the most
exotic things I saw was people display
in human interaction in public at the
airport flight gates what else was my
experience like I have so much going
through my head right now like I can't
even tell you this being in this place
and just a lot a lot of cool stuff but
thank you so much to everybody you know
went to Perth if you've been a Perth or
not in Australia but it's basically it's
like somebody it you know it's it almost
looked like it went out of business and
then they just restarted it back up and
we went to Brisbane where else I went to
Adelaide that was a wild it was like
kind of a sleepy time I couldn't tell
what place was kind of like what like if
okay if this city is more like Chicago
or if this city is more like New York or
if this city is more like Tampa I think
I needed more time people think a lot of
times that the trip when you're touring
doing a shows that it's like vacation
it's not it's work you know it's a lot
of come and go and I just want to thank
so many nice people reached out and
brought gifts there's still a couple
gifts that people brought me to the last
show that I haven't even opened up yet
some nice t-shirts and MMA guys came and
one of them had a move called the hard
scarf then uh you know this guy on my
neighborhood used to put people in
somebody wore a r.i.p Billy conforto
shirt it was it was a next-level man it
was next level I just can't believe it
I'm like how did all these people know
that I was coming I mean I mean I know
they know because like the podcast and
because of social media but it just
doesn't it didn't didn't add up really
into my head like that this many people
would would be here and so I just want
to say thank you and we did it you know
we did it you know it's one thing I'm
realizing when I walk on that stage and
there's people out there that we did
this and that if you are somebody who is
wondering if you can do something that
you want to do I'm not like preaching at
you or anything but but honestly man
I've doubted myself every every step
along the way I've doubted myself and
and I still doubt myself
but I've but I have not but uh but I'm
but I'm doing it but I'm doing it but
I'm not but I haven't really stopped my
feet from moving forward you know and
I'm not telling you that's a preachy or
anything I just I'm just trying to find
a way to share some of my experience in
case there's somebody like me you know
who wanders wolf what do I do you know
if I want to do you know chase a dream
or do this or do that and there's a
little voice inside of you whatever it
is that will tell you the right thing to
do next or it'll it'll convince you from
time to time and sometimes that little
voice might even be the voice of
somebody outside of you that catches
your frequency and and uh yeah just I
don't know I'm saying I could think I'm
selling kind of preaching oh let's take
a call actually you know what I want to
talk about this I was man on this past
tour you know I was out of town for
three weeks and I want to thank you guys
for putting up with everything while we
were out of the studio and you know it's
uh one thing I noticed was I was I was
you know they had a tour manager so a
tour manager so somebody like kind of
meets you along the tour and takes you
you know like take you from one city to
the next and just make sure you kind of
know what's going on in each place
especially since its international and I
realize like I found myself getting real
antsy with the with the tour management
group and they were great
I just noticed about myself like man I
gotta get real short with him when I see
him in the morning I'll he'd be like and
I would be like just like a just kind of
like a cranky kid and I wasn't thinking
like what the [ __ ] is going on man
like I don't behave this way what is
going on and I started to realize it
took me man it took me probably the
first four cities I think they didn't
really know what like by the end of the
day I would be nicer but in the
beginning I was just so like I was just
short with people I wouldn't look him in
the eyes and I wasn't like I was being
mean I was being mean right but I wasn't
doing it on purpose I was just
uncomfortable
I just didn't feel good and I knew that
I was not feeling good I just didn't
know what to do and I started to realize
that I don't like I don't like it when
people have to help me like I don't like
getting help from other people you know
I want to do stuff on my own
like I can do it that's what I think to
myself I can't I don't need help I can
do this you know I don't want anybody to
help me you know I don't need anybody I
can do it better or I can do I can do it
and I'm just kind of talking about that
because you know I needed help I just
didn't want to admit it I didn't want to
I don't know I was just oh I just always
been so used to doing things for myself
that that I didn't want to say that I
couldn't do them for my software that I
wanted to even let somebody else have
the opportunity to help me I didn't want
anybody to have the opportunity to help
me because if you help me then somehow
that's like a weakness of mine if you
help me then it shows me that that I'm
able that I'm capable of like connecting
then I'm in a weakness because I'm
trying to get these words right if I let
you help me why don't I like people
helping me because I can do it myself
and if you realize that I and if I let
you see that I can't do it myself or if
I let you help me and then it I'm just
trying to get these I'm trying to get my
feelings hooked to my words um sorry if
this is kind of all over the place but
this is just something that's really
been really really hit me this on this
trip because I never had this type of
experience you know I just didn't want
to look people in the eyes I didn't want
to like if I needed like if you were
helping me I didn't want you to see see
the look in my eyes that look that
showed that I knew you were helping me
I was keeping that to myself like I just
didn't want I didn't want to be someone
who needs help because to me it was like
a weakness you know it was like it gave
you like an ability to connect with me
that I just wasn't ready for you know
I'm right I'm finally being friends I'm
fine with you know joking around I'm
fine with having fun but when it came to
a moment where I needed you because you
knew something that I didn't or that you
when when it came to a moment where I
was gonna show you that I couldn't help
myself
or that that was a moment I just
couldn't do I couldn't do those moments
where it looked like I couldn't fend for
myself I don't know I know something
that's all over the place and I'm sorry
but I was really just trying to figure
it out I'll just mute I just don't like
that you know I like to be able to do
things I'm just so used to it like I
think it at a level even inside of me in
the fabric of me like in the
stitching of my core you know I think I
just realized at a certain point in my
life vit you know when it a youthful
point that or something or even when I
was a zygote that I'm gonna have to do
this myself and and that's what I'm
gonna do and so I'm not I'm never not
gonna do that it's almost like I made a
deal with myself like I'm never not
gonna do this myself
and so now that the touring gets a
little different and people are on board
and people are helping it's like it's
really tough for me to let somebody help
me that's one thing I've kind of
realized it's really really tough for me
to let somebody help me
and it ending in it I almost have an
adverse reaction to it because if I show
you that I need help from you then that
means that that that gives you an
ability to connect with me and that's
scary to me I think so that's why I
think I don't know some of the stuff I
need to do a little bit of work on and
think about but it was just something
that was heavily on my mind so I want to
share it with you guys but thank you so
much to everybody in Australia that came
out I'm happy to be back home I have
some jetlag I just literally about seven
minutes ago there's got hit by jet like
pretty heavy which is a tough tough
thing to try and explain how you're
feeling at the same time and I'm sorry
for taking you guys on that wormhole but
I just don't I wish I knew exactly what
I was thinking more but man I just it
really it really hurts me somewhere to
admit that I need help or to admit that
I that I'm not doing something by myself
you know it just makes me feel scared
it's a scary thing and I didn't know
that until I was on this experience and
I'm in another country and you know
there's a group people that are helping
out and they're helping and I'm just I
was so upset and I couldn't figure out
why and I wasn't upset with the audience
her like he had the shows or I didn't
there wasn't anything like that it was
all just you know behind the scenes and
and so I'm grateful that the tour
manager and and their company like put
up with me for a couple days while
figured it out and then I started going
to some different 12-step meetings and
it helped me kind of calm down and get
into a better space but anyway enough
about that man I want to take a couple
of calls that came in here we go oh hi
oh what's up Christian over there in
Ohio thank you for calling man homeward
I am 40 years old and he said something
not that long ago you said something
like I'm afraid to let myself grow up
with the things without the things I
always wanted because they're not there
and it made me think a lot and I was
like wow there's a lot of things that I
thought I would have by the time I'm 40
or things that I thought I would do came
trans man that was really something that
was a bucket list item but I never
really thought I don't know it was
something I would have to work a long
time to be able to do one time and amen
I just wanted to give it a shot so
tonight we got about 5 minutes and I'm
going to give it a go so on thank you
for the inspiration and the last and all
that so yeah we're man well thank you
for calling it with that dude good luck
with that first time Wow
yeah look I think sometimes it's like
you know we create these story have
these stories that get built into us
that we can't do certain things you know
I was just talk
with a friend of mine yesterday you know
she's going on a vacation and she just
spent you know like $5,000 to go on a
vacation which is a big sum of money and
it's a vacation you know and she said
you know I just you know I never knew if
I could
she's like as I'm spending the money
she's like if something felt wrong about
it and she's like I was it felt wrong
because I was spending the money on
something that I wanted to do for myself
and not spending the money on just some
like oh you have to save for this you
have to save for that or you have to
have this savings plan or it was like it
was it was like against the norm it was
just me spending money on something that
I wanted for myself even a good
experience like travel like you can't
just up and travel for a month and she's
like yes I can she's like and as I did
it it just felt so wrong but at the same
time it just felt so kind of perfect
like oh this is what I'm supposed to do
this is I'm supposed to do things that I
want to do in the world I'm supposed to
do new experiences I'm not just supposed
to save every dime and put it away in
this shoebox or put it away for this and
have safekeeping and and never try the
things I always wanted to try and it
really hit me I was like wow that's so
interesting when yeah when you spend
money on something that you kind of want
sometimes especially like a thing like
travel or a musical instrument or or
doing something nets that you've always
wanted to do but that's out of the
societal norm
it feels foreign almost to us because
someone we get to built into this world
where it's like oh this is the next
thing oh you go to okay you go finish
school then you go to college then you
did get this and then you get a job and
then you get another job and then it's
like well what if we didn't do it that
way what if one day I just said to my
boss hey I'm gonna go for a month and
travel which is what my friend is doing
you know she said I'm gonna go for a
month and travel and then I bought the
ticket and next thing you know I feel
like I'm wandering out into a whole
different
world of interaction with life than I
have been previously because I'm doing
something that I want to do but yeah
like you said it's like you think it can
take you know you thought Santa but
something yet a try you know worked out
for a long time just to get them and
even try did I remember I drove across
the causeway about thirty miles I've
been upset my whole life that my dad was
so old when I was born and I've been
making fun of him in my head to make me
feel okay about him being so old and
then I just stood up on stage and
started telling jokes about it and so it
was just you know it's and everybody has
their own experience but getting up and
talking about something that's just been
running around in your head you know a
lot of the work for trying stand-up has
already been done you've been alive
that's the research the research for
doing stand-up in the practice is being
alive now the the repetition is
something that takes you know time but
the ability for it for you to do it to
have the Gunpowder that's already packed
inside of you and the microphone that's
just the that's the Flint and that's
what's gonna light it but let's hear the
rest of your call thank you for calling
in Christian yeah man great I wanted to
thank you and share the fact that I'm
gonna get up on stage late today and
either shoot myself and make the people
that well gang brother and I hope it
went good let's take another call here
here we go the hotline is always is nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three what's up do you know my name is
chase I've been seeing this girl for
about a year and a half now and what's
okay thank you for calling you've been
seeing a girl for a year and a half it's
a long time these days it's a
it's almost like a first marriage
homework and we've been on and off so we
were never truly official and I guess
maybe that's partially my fault and I
could have missed that but uh basically
what's happened here is about three
weeks ago I finally asked this girl to
be my girlfriend there you go boy
you sliding in and that deal deal be oh
you want that uh-huh
would you be my boyfriend my girlfriend
let's hear more and yes which is awesome
but my best friend let me know that uh
he hooked up with this girl about a
month and a half ago when we weren't
officially together so I'm dealing with
this whirlwind of emotion feeling bad
feeling bad feeling betrayed and not
really sure what to do and I does seem
like it was a mistake that they both
regret but I just feel hurt man and I'm
trying to figure out how to move forward
with this so give any advice is the path
to forgiveness the right way to go gang
gang you're the man gang gang bruh I'm
barely a man by genetic coding only man
the rest of me
let's hit or miss some days dude cuz I
can be a real bad yeah you know it this
makes me think K when I was you when I
was um when I was in school when I was
in high school I was in love with this
girl she had been seeing some guy before
me that she lost her virginity to right
and and you know what I'm saying some
girls you know you they lose the
virginity and then C then you come along
and you you you take their West's
virginity and that's usually you know be
whole sex that's the be whole deal is
there West virginity but but anyway that
was just that was just kind of a joke
but what I'm saying is this man I never
got over the fact that she had already
hooked up with some other guy before we
got together I never got over it
I always let it just fester on me and
just this weird jealousy it gave me a
thing to be angry about and in the end
that [ __ ] was all about me man and was
you know it had nothing to do with her
this girl has just been living her life
you know and the guy that she hooked up
with I actually really liked that guy
and he was a friend of mine and you know
and when you're young it's hard to not
be jealous but I would just say [ __ ]
man at least you people you know at
least you know you're in the right
ballpark because if they've already
hooked up then you're really the missing
link you know it's like oh if you're if
your friends are one of them you like
the other one you know I think you could
probably get past it pretty quick I
would just you know it's really going to
be super meta it's gonna be the the move
is to get past it it's gonna be super
macho of you and you and you need to
tell them you forgive them just you got
to do it inside of yourself I think you
know that's what I wish I would have
done
now what I did here's something else you
could do what I did was hold it against
the girl bringing up all the time we
were drunk fight about it cry about it
in the front yard cry about it in the
back yard
you could go my route and you might not
be reward
I mean it's it's a painful route to go
you wind up laying on your back out on
the street in the middle of the night
smoking menthols bra smoking them
[ __ ] on a pack of Winston menthols
Limited Editions 110s dude you ever
smoked a pack of 110 menthols dunk come
on boy dude the thing so the UH the
cherries so big on the end of those
cigarettes damn mosquitoes show up for
it
thing's wild so I would say yeah man I
go I go that forgiveness right and be
that big dog be the big dog he still got
the best friend you still got the girl
so they hooked up one time
well you know who do you do whatever you
got to do you know and if you got two
years later maybe if the guy you know
you know maybe years from now the guy
you know you have an opportunity you
know maybe he breaks up with a girl and
you hook up with her and then y'all are
even if you want to you know do it games
of Thrones style but otherwise I just
let it ride man
you know you just don't want to miss out
on the opportunity for a good
relationship with a girl because of some
jealousy especially if you if your dude
isn't like you know still trying to
holler at her I think that's the move
but also bro [ __ ] do I know son but gang
man be good to yourself you know what I
was thinking was this man I'd love to
know a lot of guys you know we we did
this a couple years ago a lot of girls
or guys if you want to hit the hotline
with this we can put some of these calls
in the first time you touch somebody's
Crocs you know of the opposite sex or it
could also even be your own crotch that
OC the first time you know we had a
woman a couple years ago she called in
and the first time I got her little you
know that little uh you know what I'm
talking about that little Vietnamese hot
pocket you feel me that vagina was in a
frigerator box in an empty refrigerator
box out back in the garage and everybody
has a secret a sexy little story like
that you know you snuggled up in the
frigerator box with a young lover and
they touch your crotch for the first
time cuz it dude I remember when I was
young
my crotch was like the center of the
universe boy I mean they would have a
falcon would come in laying on my crotch
at night and look out over the lands you
know your crotch was the only member
during a pervert II brought your crotch
was the your crotch was our
nucleus of the universe you'd have
people you know you'd have people lining
up outside of your crotch looking for
you know bread or milk and bread your
crotch was everything all you you know
of if a fly went by your crotch you're
freakin shuddered a little bit it just
you had so much energy all your hormones
was crime was crowded up in your crotch
like there was you know like 30 people
stuck in a [ __ ] church van or
something the energy remember that so
hit the hotline nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three we'll put some
of those uh those FTC s's on those
first-time crotch stories on the next
episode and I don't do that to be gross
and I don't want you to leave a gross
message please but I do want you to just
tell me about the feelings the
experience you had the first time where
was it you know I know a buddy of mine
the pizza delivery guy had been drinking
and he went off the road crashed his car
and then he was in arm he had a little
dimension he walked away from the pizza
vehicle and my buddy and his girl they
snuck up in there on the second date and
touched you and touched each other's
junk out there off of Lee Road so
everybody has a neat story imagine that
the first time you get in the handful of
that of that judy judy and somebody and
they got a you know a faint smell of
[ __ ] pepperoni in the air I mean
Jesus Christ brah
is it Christmas it should be Kim yeah
yup and you can hit the hotline ninety
five six six four nine five zero three
for those ftcs men that first time a
crotch story onward hey man
love your podcast do love what you do
thank you brother
and I appreciate you calling in today
man and I almost happy early fathers
down there that's coming up I'm not sure
if you're a father but you could be I
think you're just the greatest
storyteller of this time well that's
nice you to say that man
you know we don't do much to keep
stories alive anymore you know I feel
like they're dying you know I feel like
a lot of people don't care what the
story is in in media these days they
just want to just put out something
quick and easy in and even stories have
become clickbait and so I'm just I feel
very blessed to have a gift to even tell
a story but thank you for the nice words
on work but anyway my name is Dylan I'm
from Florence Alabama I worked for the
railroad and a lot of times I'm a
conductor so a lot of times we get on
the train you know we'll get through
different places and stuff like that one
of the places we go is Memphis Tennessee
or Memphis some some people call it you
know oh yeah and that's Memphis in the
East tab if you drove outside of Memphis
about an hour
you could go to Graceland too and they
had a man out there doing Graceland I
guess you know he got upset that Elvis
had done it and he said well damn I'm
gonna do mine and you go there at night
and me and to my friends one went there
one night and uh and the man wasn't
there you could knock on his door and he
would take you on a tour Museum of his
own house and it was all Elvis
memorabilia
it's called Graceland - and what
happened was uh we went there my friend
got bit by a damn huge [ __ ] dog
showed up and bit my friend and it was a
black dog or black and brown so I don't
know that isn't I mean it's not has
nothing to do with the but it uh but
yeah we had to take my buddy to the
hospital and all kinds of [ __ ] so we
never got to go inside but anyway let's
hear more there's a pretty rough area
there man and you know it's one of those
places where if you don't know where you
are in Memphis you you might not need to
stop at the gas station oh yeah if you
don't know where you are in Memphis you
might be dead I don't be seen 48 hours
but a lot of that the first 48 sorry and
it's about people in Memphis shooting
each other and then the cops kind of
don't know who it is but they know who
it is
let's hear more someplace is there that
call the gas stations murder marks
[Music]
well the barbecued chips will you better
get your chips quick son so but anyway I
just want to know what you think if you
ever been to Memphis what you think
about it about the area and stuff like
that but but anyway gang gang brother
gang gang man I mean I think you have a
lot of cities in America where they have
you know some of the crime problem has
gotten a little bit out of hand in
specific areas you know Memphis is one
of those places where you're getting a
lot of crime you know places you see a
lot of poverty you know you have a lot
of it places where you see also a lot of
poverty and black community you have a
lot of um you have a lot of crime you
know because over time it's been one of
the more impoverished you know and also
they have a lot of like a lot of
gangsters and in that sort of thing and
you know you see a lot of those guys
with you know also all you know making
like guns and murder and that type of
stuff look cool so I think it is that's
something you probably have in Memphis
is a lot of that you know in New Orleans
they have it Chicago has it in ones it
seems to be getting real bad or just the
newspapers say there is if you go to
nola.com it's you know it just seems to
be something that happens in some of
these communities where it's hard to uh
it's like how do you eradicate this
problem I think some of it is time you
know you get you know as more
opportunity you have more opportunity
and a lot of different you know for
different ethnicities in in America more
opportunity to make money than you'll
see you know more comfortable lifestyles
where it won't be as much you know as
much crime and as much poverty but yeah
I think sometimes the onus could also be
taken on by some of these individual
communities it's like you
it would be you know it's like how does
how do you stop this kind of stuff
within these communities it's like I
would love you know and maybe this does
happen and I just don't see it it's like
how do you stop like black on black
violence like you know it's scary
sometimes too I remember growing up in
Louisiana it would be scary sometimes to
have a black friend because if a lot of
black guys got murdered and you just
would read about it every day on the
newspaper see it on the news like damn
man it's scary you know it uh and then I
think it's not a it gives a scary vibe
too you know it's I can't even imagine
do being young black guy in some of
those places would be scary and look I'm
sure it's all types of ethnicities and
it's all types of people and stuff so I
don't even know what I'm talking about
but I think over time some of that will
go away but some of it is it's just like
we got a you know like if we if we
continue to champion this sort of like
that it's cool to be like a gangster and
that kind of [ __ ] then I don't know if
that kind of stuff gets helped you know
some of it's a culture thing some of it
say like what's cool but then also it
might be fun as [ __ ] to be a straight-up
gangster bruh be running around at night
playing you know you know all the the
kids that you know who have two parents
and a little bit of cash they're inside
playing modern warfare and the kids
who's out there struggling those dudes
you're out there [ __ ] running ducking
over about a murder mark trying to drink
a [ __ ] get through with all 32 ounces
before they go to that big gulp in the
sky the Lord before they go see the Lord
it's the freakin murder mark but all
aboard bro you know I get that
bulletproof train son get that
bulletproof glass on the front of the
Train all aboard
but yeah Memphis [ __ ] dude first 48
gives a bad vibe to that city in the
sense that you just everybody's shooting
at each other over there it always seems
like but yeah I think sometimes that's a
community problem where it's like how do
you you know like
you know it's it's everybody's problem
but it's also it's like it within
certain communities you have some things
that just after a while seems like are
these things gonna go away or maybe they
are going away and the media's just
keeps playing them up and acting like
they aren't you know I don't know I wish
I kind of knew more sometimes but you
know the [ __ ] do I know man let's hear
another call here we go hey Theo my name
is Carla I'm from Seattle Washington
what's up Kyle and I'll be up there in
two weeks up there in Seattle onward I
just wanted to talk to you about Bali
and me and my fiance are going there for
our honeymoon and the end of July man
that's awesome well that's exciting to
hear that you guys have a honeymoon
coming up and that you guys have each
other you guys are gonna get to be over
there and it's really I think romantic
that's one thing I wish I don't have and
I'd have been there was just a romance
you know I didn't have a romance they
had a guy that brought breakfast over to
my place in the morning a little guy you
know a beautiful guy named a dae-hwa and
he seemed hella chill and you know good
with the eggs good with the omelet tree
and he'd bring that through and rolled
through with that I got this you know
the milos so gang in married I'm
delighted for it so I just wanted to see
what he thought about Bali man I know I
heard a little bit on your laptop now
you said that it was like really good
people and those dogs with the big ice
balls but yeah man you know let me know
what the heck you really liked about it
was it the food or the culture of people
I'm ready to get my ice crab along so
Jen gang I love what you're doing over
there you're all open about your
feelings things like that I appreciate
that though well thank you man I'm
excited for you guys you guys got it you
guys got engaged you getting married in
July man you're heading over there what
a lot what a great I mean this is just
gonna be probably one of the best
summers of your life you know or not bet
I mean it will be a great summer you
know we'll be like an amazing summer
will be a special summer that's what I
mean you know it would be a special
summer summertime
man anything could happen in the summer
the Sun gets fired the Sun gets hot the
Sun puts on sunglasses that's when you
know the party start girls you'll see a
girl you know maybe she didn't even have
any breasts before now she gots a little
bit of breast maybe your buddy even
shows up with a couple of fricken a
couple of beet coops boy on him you know
what I'm saying no breasts II Jeff rolls
up you're like damn Jeff got them Milky
front pieces and anything can happen
it's summertime sandcastles you know
somebody hides a bottle of [ __ ] nah
you know raspberry schnapps out there
and a [ __ ] sand dune and you guys
getting liquored up and you out there
talking about witchcraft and touching
each other's junk over there over there
in the salt water off of Perdido Bay
anything can happen you know you might
be out there you might they might have a
girl who puts her mouth on the ground a
sucker crustacean right out the one of
them ditch crawfish right out the damn
ditch bang and who knew that would get
you erect just watching that watching a
girl you know just face take a
crustacean you know watching a girl just
just face take a damn shrimp right out
of the earth with her lung power it's
beautiful meaning anything could happen
it's summer summer solstice summer
summer slam do wrestlers are excited
they're [ __ ] slamming each other
I mean it's summertime and anything can
happen man but I'm glad you guys are
getting that marriage you're gonna be
over in Bali I recommend it I recommend
you stay in Changu or you get even more
rural than Changu that's where I was
seminyak seems a little too too much
going on you can get out into if you
really want to be by the beach just fine
are more rural place I think as long as
you get like a little villa or something
the more rural the better but the people
are so kind you're gonna really be able
to relax you know I would try to keep my
phone off as much as possible and just
do your best to
to spend time together I think it sounds
like you guys are really gonna knock it
out of the park you know you could rent
scooters but I also enjoy just getting a
you know a little scooter and getting on
somebody's back and holding onto
somebody you don't know taking a chance
you know it's the closest I've been to a
successful relationship really was
jumping on the back of a scooter and now
I didn't know if it was a man or woman
in the helmet and just you know and just
riding with him taking a chance man so
but yeah fresh fruit
you know just drink bottled water you
know that drill yeah I'm trying to think
of anything else like I didn't do it I
don't do a lot of nightlife or anything
so I was lowkey up early it was
beautiful man it was beautiful I don't
think you I don't I don't think that you
could go wrong let's take another call
right here this is Bruce from Rochester
or neck neck tat country Rochester that
ROC boy
shoutout to my boy Baggins dude who
passed away a couple years ago yo deed
over there by the Pizza Hut by the Days
Inn and uh you know he was hopped up I
think he you know was on them ludes and
on that garbage plate bro he got a
caught a thick garbage plate and
couldn't couldn't get it down bro gang
bro Oh word I just want to leave a
comment on the podcast you had with
Chris Lilley when you're talking about
you have a dream about him I just wanted
to mention that I actually I also have a
dream about you the night before oh okay
this is wild man cuz I never been down
this territory where I'm talking to a
man that had a dream about me and so I'm
curious to see how how this will go
let's hear more brother thank you for
calling and we were I was in a comedy
club and it was very crowded I was
trying to make my way out of the club
and you were trying to make your way
through the club trying to go through
the crowd there there was a little break
in the people and so we met up the ham
this [ __ ] is getting ear on it
uh-huh or maybe not maybe she's two guys
passing in a club about to find out
in my dream and when I try to pass by
you you get a new look kind of a little
bit of an attitude will huff and puff
okay then this sounds like me at the
beginning of my comedy tour behind the
scenes man I was Hufflepuff in man and I
was getting Slytherin and then I started
to kind of really Gryffindor out towards
the end homeward now when I went by you
like I was in your way and I know it was
just a dream but I do still feel like
maybe you owe me an apology and so I
just wanted to put that out there listen
I understand where you're coming from if
you don't apologize but I just felt like
you know maybe I was the right thing to
do at this point
gang game oh you know with a apology for
the subconscious behavior you know what
man I will apologize it's uh I don't
need to be right man
I'm sorry you know I'm sorry man I think
out with that that you know I have had
some of that behavior recently I think
I've been in a lot of fear about just
things changing in my life and just not
knowing how to act and you know just
worried about how people are gonna think
of me and worried if I'm deserving of
different opportunities and um just
worried like if the world is like
tricking me you know worried if the
world is like just tricking me and
saying oh well here's something you're
gonna be able to get to do but then
we're just tricking you you're gonna
wake up or you're gonna some harsh
realities gonna show up and change
things and I know some stuff we don't
have control over but I could see myself
probably if I was in my subconscious
walking past somebody giving them kind
of a little bit of her you know a haram
so I'm sorry about that you know I'm
sorry about that dude I could have you
know I could have made the choice to be
seeing you and just giving you a smile
and giving you a thumbs
or you know no thumbs-up which is also a
new thing a lot of people are doing two
hands out closed fist thumb tucked away
inside the hand no thumbs up
people like wouldn't them wouldn't the
hell's going on
but it's cool looking alright guy no
thumbs up and that's like a Japanese
thing that's like a nude it's like that
piece on but it's like newer than that
so I'm sorry I did that man and next
time we see each other yeah keep your
chakras open because I'll make sure to
you know give you a little bit of an
elbow you know a fist bump or something
hearty something lovable you know maybe
just you know I'll do have a little bit
time I'll do a quick little beat or a
little baton twirl you know show you a
little bit of flair or something put a
little uh put a little pendant on you on
your lapel maybe something you know
something that says vote for Jerry or
something you know and then another
pendant that says who the [ __ ] is Jerry
so that way you kind of get the full
deal we had some patreon questions we're
gonna get to him next time I in this
jetlag is literally shutting my face
down I don't know if I don't think he's
anything else just to share at the
moment I just want to apologize to
anybody I know there's some times where
people will reach out and like I try to
get people tickets and a lot of times I
try to help and and a lot of times
tickets are sold out so two shows be
careful there's a lot of second and
third party websites that will sell
tickets at extraordinary prices those
are not the regular ticket sites those
are second and third party you got to
look at the name it can be sometimes
they'll make the name just like
Ticketmaster it'll be like lick it
master and it tickets $200 for the show
I don't sell tickets at those higher
prices so if you see something going on
like that that's not a natural ticket
and you want that natural choice you
know you don't want that breach birth
ticket you know you you think you're
coming to see me and you go to see LA I
love it and his mother and they doing
knitting or something we're doing you
know yoga Lee
ah yeah man my brain is a little bit
fried from the trip but I'm happy to be
home I'm in a new studio I have no clue
what's gonna happen you know but I'm
this the risk that I'm willing to take
right now you know because I've learned
some from a previous experience when we
took the first risk of what you know it
was good and maybe we're overstepping
our bounds and getting more space I
don't know so I'm curious to see you
know how we'll fill this space and if
we'll fill it and with what you know but
I feel like it's some new opportunity
and I feel like I've been feeling a lot
of like inspiration recently to do some
cool like giving back and outreach type
of stuff and I don't I don't know what
that's gonna be but I can really feel it
starting to gestate inside of me but
thank you guys for your patience thank
you guys for being here today
thanks for the calls as always the
hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three we had some great
patreon questions from Matthew
Puccinelli Marisa Bruno Olivia a bear
Sierra Smith Mike Nucci and Quinn Hasan
and I'll get to some of those next week
but how you guys be good yourselves man
on the way out let's go out with some
Jameson flood every night
[Music]
[Applause]
it was me
[Music]